nous avons des résidents qui sont là
tout le temps dans les habitent ici un
ce sont leurs lieux de vie ils reçoivent
leur famille ils font des repas avec
leur famille au sein de la structure les
familles ont la possibilité de venir
déjeuner ils sortent ils vont en
vacances ils reviennent ils vont passer
les week-ends en famille nous avons des
activités qui sont proposées dans les
étages avec les soignants qui font des
activités d'un journée vous avez un
animateur qui est là aussi fait
d'activités tout le temps et vous avez
ce que nous avons un pôle d'activités en
seront adaptés ce ne sont pas des on va
dire c'est vraiment maintenir les
capacités préserver de nos résidents
[Musique]
il yal amalgame de tout alors que ces
paliers à tous les étages c'est toute la
profession qui est touché 1 par rapport
à ça mais ils se disent qu'ils ne sont
pas concernés voilà ils ne se sentent
pas concernés ils ne se reconnaissent
pas à travers ce type de pratiques et on
se reconnaît pas non plus chez coria les
soldes ce non pas du tout mais même les
familles peuvent vous le dire
nous avons notre psychologue donc qui
est référente justement bientraitance
pas plus tard que le dit elle avait déjà
organisé deux formations avec les
équipes 1 donc et aussi vous avez korian
donc nous avons pas mal de formations
dans le catalogue de formations korian
et donc nous avons ce qu'on appelle des
formations best dont une partie avec
justement la bientraitance de nos aînés
[Musique]